ما حدث بالاعتداء الغاشم مشيره الى ان
قيادتها اجرت اتصالات مع كل من الاليه
الرباعيه ومجموعه الوساطه واطلعتهم على
الامر
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم و متابعه الله تطورات
ينضموا الى الكاتب الصحفي خالد الفكه خالد
معنا في هذه التغطيه كيف تتابع هذه
التطورات وكيف يمكن توصيف ماجد الان في
الخرطوم وبقيه المناطق السودانيه
يعني حرب حرب بين القوات المسلحه والدعم
السبيله الان سمعنا ان هناك عدد من القتلى
وان هناك يعني
بدت يعني تصدر وتخرج عدد من
من المدنيين جراء هذه الاشتباكات وتبادل
الاسلحه الثقيله في
الخرطوم الان التكات تكون الحركه يعني
الوسط الخرطوم عاد انتشار كثيف للجيش
السوداني
وملحقات وتبادل اشتباكات بين الجيش وعناصر
الدعم السريع الوضعي هو الان يعني يمكن ان
يقال تماما نحن الان في اجواء الحربي
وتبادل
الاسلحه الثقيله الان هناك بعض المصادر
لتتحدث عن هدوء حذر في هذه اللحظات ربما
لاول مره من الاحاديث والشبكات من صباح
اليوم يعني هل
عايشت هذا الهدوء الحذر في هذا التوقيت
نعم نعم يعني انا انا يعني اقل من ساعه
ونصف كان هناك اسماء قويه اطلاق مكثف ربما
الان يعني قلت
هذه الاصوات قلت ولكن ربما يكون هو هو
يعني هذا الهدوء الذي يعني على الاقل
الخرطوم منذ الصباح كانت يعني الطلقات
الناريه وسقوط لبعض
الدانات في منازل المدنيين ويصاب النازلين
ومنازلهم ولكن دون احصائيات يعني
لانه يصعب في هذه اللحظه استاذ احمد
الحصول على احصائي
ات مكافه الاطراف في بعض المعلومات والحرب
بين الجيش والدعم السريع ولكن انا استطيع
ان اقول الان الخرطوم يعني يعني اضحك
واصبحت على وضعي مخيف وحذرنا منه طويلا
وكثيرا بان الصدام المسلح اذا وقع يعني
ستكون كلفته ليس على العسكريين سيطال
المدنيين والمشاكل المدنيه والضحايه وسقوط
ضحايا مدنيين يعني انا الان حاولت ان يعني
اذهب الى وسط الخرطوم وجدت صعوبه من خلال
الانتشار
العسكري ومخافه تبادل النيران يعني على
الاقل في مثلا في جبره في منطقه منطقه
القريبه يعني هي
في خرطوم جنوب يعني تبعد ربما يعني اقل من
10 كيلو الخرطوم يعني هناك تبادل اطلاق
النيران ومن الصعب ان تذهب في ظل يعني هذا
هذا الامر هكذا يعني بالاضافه لتبادل
اطلاق النار بشكل التقليدي الذي شاهدناه
ايضا هناك مشاركه للطيران الحربي الذي
يبدو انه يقصف مناطق داخل العاصمه الخرطوم
هل رصدت هذه المناطق يبدو يبدو واضحا ان
الجيش الان يعني اتخذ الخطه الذي تسمح له
باستخدام الطيران
لمقار الدعم السريع
ويعطوانه الان اصبحت هي قوات كما قال انهم
متمرده ويريد ان يقطع اي ميلاد لقواته
للقوات وان يسيطر من خلال استخدام سلاح
الطيران في ظل يعني شعائر النيران المشتعل
الذي واصدقاء التي والدعنات التي يعني
وقعت في مطار الخصوم ويعني راينا كيف ان
هناك اشتعال بعد الطائرتين في في مدرج
الخرطوم مما يعني ان الان المرافق
الاشتراكيه تواجه خطر تمام في ظل سمعنا ان
هناك عدد كبير من المسافرين هم الان حديثي
الصلاه وحديثه بل هناك مواطنين الان ذهبوا
للاختباء يعني ياتي برومات العمارات
والطابق المباني العاليه فهذا يعني كله
يشير الى الحاله التي يعيش فيها المواطن
السوداني الان بل الان يعني اش
اهد
الصفات في محطات محطات الوقود هذه النشيخ
بان هناك يعني من هذه الارتال سيد خالد
تابعه لاي جهه او لاي طرف
مرحله يعني اقتصاد الازمه مما يعني الان
ربما تكون هناك نجره في في المواد
الاساسيه والسلع
المواطنين في المحاوله يعني شراء اكبر عدد
من احتياجاتهم المنزليه يعني مخافه وعدم
معرفه يعني متى يتوقف هذا هذا الامر
والاشتباكات وخاصه يعني الان سمعنا ان
ربما تكون هناك وساقط من حزب الامه ودعوه
يعني
تكوين وان شاء اللجنه مشتركه للتهديه بين
الطرفين كما انه الان هناك يعني هناك
وصاعفات دوليه الاوضاع والاخر من ذلك ان
السفينه الامريكي الان
الامريكيه
في الجنوبيه مما يعني ان الان لاني اصبح
غير متاح وغير الخرطوم وسط الخرطوم
بعض يعني هم الان يعني هذه اشاره واضحه
على ان مدى المخاطر التي يمكن ان تواجه
وجود المدنيين في وسط يعني وفي كل هذه
المعطيات يعني في تقديرك من الذي يتحمل
المسؤوليه حول تدهور الوضع الى هذا
المستوى هل تتفق مع ما ذهبت اليه قوى
الحريه والتغيير التي وجهت اتحدث عن
المجلس المركزي تحديدا التي وجهت الاصابع
بالاصابع الاتهام الى من اسمتهم بفلول
النظام السابق
الكلام الذي قاله وتصحيح الذي يعني اشار
به رئيسه
يعني من خلال مشاهدناه اليوم وهذه
الاشتباكات وهذه الحرب التي تزور الان
وحذر من ان اي طلقه تخرج من اي فوهه يعني
ستكون هي خساره للوطن والبلاد والابناء
البلاد وشدد على ان
السبيل اللوحه هو
التوافق والاتفاق
يعني حتى تفادي اي صدامات فبالتالي يبدو
ان القوى المدنيه وحللت منذ شهر وضعت
الكره في الطرف العسكريين الذين هم ضلوا
في مثل هذه القضايا والنتيجه كما نرى الان
هذا هذا يعني نخشى ان تتحول الخرطوم اشباح
مما شهدناه والحركه
من يتحمل مسؤوليه حول ذلك وهل هناك دور
يلعبه النظام السابق فيما يحدث الان في
خرطوم وبقيه المدن السودانيه
النظام الفائده وعناصرهم هم المستفيده
الاكبر من حاله الفوضى العارمه يعني قطع
الطريق امام الاستقرار في البلاد هذه بدون
شك واضحه وبينه فبالتالي كيف سيستفيد
النظام السابق من هكذا وضع استاذ خالد
[موسيقى]
يجب ان يعلو صوت العقل في هذه اللحظه وان
تقف هذه المعارك وان يذهب الجميع الى صوت
التهدئه وايجاد مخرج الان يعني انا كان من
خلال بعض الفضائيات يعني شاهدنا كيف
الطيران الحربي الان يحلق وهذه يعني تعني
وصول الجيش الى اعلى درجات درجات الحيطه
واستخدام الاليات الوسائل التي يعني تحسم
هذه المعرفه التي وصفها لانها معرفه
الكرامه الوطنيه اذا الان لو وضعت السودان
معقده جدا
معي الان مشاهدينا ننتقل الى مدينه مروي
وينضم الينا مراسله العربيه نزار احنا
بكنزار وما اخر ما توفى لك من معطيات حول
ما يحدث في مروي
ما يحدث احمد في مروه هي حاله الاحتقان
الامني الحاد الذي ضرب هذه المدينه
منذ الساعه 8:30 صباحا عندما دوت
الناريه داخل قاعده مرويه العسكريه وبعدها
استمعنا مباشره الى تبادل لاطلاق النار
واستماع لدوي الانفجارات هذه الاصوات عمت
كل ارجاء مدينه مروي وحتى اجزاء من مدينه
كريمه المتاخمه لها استمع عليها المواطنون
بعدها انتقلنا مباشره كما تابع الى الجزء
المتاخر لهذه القاعده واستطعنا ان نتعرف
اكثر على ان هنالك بالفعل اشتباكات حدثت
داخل هذه القاعده الجويه الاستراتيجيه
وتصاعدت منها اعمده الدخان والسنه اللعب
بفعل الاشتباك الحاد الذي حدث ما توفر
احمد الان من تحديثات اخباريه ومعلوماتيه
بان
قوات عسكريه ومدد هو الان الان في طريقه
من الاتجاه الجنوبي لمروي الى هذه المنطقه
منطقه مروي ليفاند وليدعم القوات العسكريه
السودانيه الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه هذه الجيش نزار صحيح
قوات تابعه للجيش حسب مصادر هنا عسكريه
بان هنالك قوات الدعم وسنه هي الان في
طريقها
ستصل بعد قليل الى هذه المنطقه لتعزيز
الوجود ولتعزيز القبضه الامنيه على هذه
المناطق ايضا احمد حجم الاصابات يبدو انه
في طريقه الى ان ياخذ نسب عاليه بعد
المشاهدات ايضا التي كنا قريبين منها
بمستشفى مروي العسكري وبعض الاصابات تم
نقلها الى مستشفى كريمه هذا ايضا يشير الى
حجم الاشتباكات التي كانت قد حدثات بين
المواطنين ام اصابات بين القوات العسكريه
بفعل الاشتباكات الحاده التي
كانت وما زالت حتى قبل قليل كنا نستمع الى
اصوات النار ولكن هذه اللحظات التي نحن
فيها الان معك توقفت تماما اعاد اعمده
الدخان التي تتصاعد بفعل المركبات المدمره
والاليات التي
احترقت بفعل الضرب والضربه المضاد لهذه
الاشتباكات التي وقعت صباح هذا اليوم
المواطنون ايضا كيف يتعايشون مع هذه
الاحداث غير المسبوقه في مدينتهم هل من
اصابات ايضا في صفوف المواطنين هل من
اشتباكات في المناطق الماهوله بالسكان
نزار
اعد الاصابات الطفيفه
لمواطنين كانوا يسكنون في الاحياء
المتاخمه لقاعده مروي هي اصابات طفيفه فقط
ليس هنالك من اصابات وسط المواطنين لانهم
تحركوا فور سماعهم ومشاهدتهم للاشتباكات
تحركوا مباشره الى عمق المدينه الى
الاحياء الامنه الى المناطق المتاخمه لنهر
النيل كثير منهم عبر الجسر نحو مدينه
كريمه
الخوف والرعبه الان يشكلان طوقا وسياجا
قويا على مواطني هذه المدينه الذين
يتفاعلون بدرجه عاليه مع كل المعطيات
الامنيه والعسكريه وحتى السياسيه التي
حدثت ويتساءلون في كل لحظه الى اين ستتجه
الامور ما هو مصير هذه المدينه هل ستتسع
رقعه الاحتجاء الاشتباكات لتعم المدينه هل
ستتوقف هل سيدعم الجيش هل سيدعم الدعم
السريع بعتاده عسكري هل ستصبح المدينه على
صفيح س اخن احمد ونحن نتجه الى ساعات
الليل والليل ربما تكون فيه سيناريوهات
مختلفه غير التي كانت صباحا هل سيتم
استخدام الطيران العسكري كل هذه
السيناريوهات الان مطروحه امام المشاهدين
يعني نحن شاهدنا ان الطيران العسكري كان
يمثل حضورا كبيرا في المعارك في الخرطوم
هل هناك ايضا مشاكل للطيران في معارك مروي
حتى الان فرضيه ان يشارك الطيران تظل
حاضره حتى اللحظه لكنها لم تتنزل الى ارض
الواقع سيناريوهات المقبله قابله احمد
للتطبيق اذا ما استمر الوضع على هذا النحو
اذا ما استمر التظاهيت في العاصمه الخرطوم
او في مدن اخرى يمكن ان يتصاعد ايضا هنا
في مرويه هذا الامر يمضي بتباينات مختلفه
ويمضي وفق منحنى يرتفع وينخفض وبالتالي
التكهنات ربما تكون عسير بعض الشيء لكن
المؤكد ان الوضع الان ملتبس هنالك حاله من
عدم الاستقرار حاله من الخوف حاله من
التوتر القياده العسكريه هنا في الفرقه
التاسعه عشر مشاه في مدينه مروي خليه نحل
الاجتماعات متواصله ترتيبات اداريه وامنيه
واستخباراتيه للتعاطي مع هذه الوضعيه
الجديده التي تعيشها منطقه مروي وقاعده
مروي ومدينه مروي والولايه الشماليه على
عمومياتها احمد وهنا سؤال ايضا حول
الولايه ح الشماليه او المسؤولين في مدينه
مدنيه صدر منهم تعليق على هذه الاحداث ام
ان الكلمه فقط هي لقوات المسلحه السودانيه
باختصار شديد
هي القوات المسلحه السودانيه عبر البيانات
وعبر الارشادات وعبر التوجيهات وعبر
التكتيكات في الميدان التنفيذيين ليس
هنالك اي بيان سوى تهدئه المواطنين نتوقع
في هذا اللحظات ان تكون ليله امن الولايه
الشماليه منعقده في دنقله او عبر التواصل
مشترك مع القياده العسكريه هنا في مدينه
مروي الان الكل يعمل من اجل وضع الامور في
نصابها هذا هو الملخص الاخير لما الاوضاع
في مدينه مروي شكرا لك من مدينه مروان كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه نزار مشاهدينا كما
نتابع في الخبر العاجل مصادر العربيه
تتحدث عن ان القاهره طالبت بوقف اطلاق نار
بين في في حديث مع المسؤولين في السودان
العسكريه طبعا الجيش السوداني ايضا ما زال
يسيطر على مدينه مراووي كما افاد مراسل
قبل قليل ننتقل الان مشاهدينا الى الخرطوم
ومعنى رئيس تحرير صحيفه السوداني عطاف
محمد مختار اهلا بك سيد عطاف معنا في هذه
التغطيه بدايه كيف تتابع يبدو اننا ايضا
فقدنا الاتصال مع الطاف سنحاول العوده
اليه من جديد اعود اليكم مره اخرى سيد
خالد الفقي الكاتب الصحفي من الخرطوم
بدايه في تقديرك يعني هل اطلقت هذه
المواجهات رصاصه الرحمه العمليه السياسيه
في السودان وما صاحبها من توقيع الاتفاق
الاطاري وما كان ايضا يعد له توقيع
الاتفاق النهائي ايضا كختام لهذه العمليه
السياسيه
نعم نعم نعم اعتقد ان العمليه السياسيه هي
تم تشريها تماما
ولن هناك اي امكانيه مجددا
للدخول السياسيين في المشهد بعد اليوم
اعتقد ان القوات المسلحه هي ستتولى زمام
الامر تماما وربما تتجه يعني فيما بعد حسم
هذه المعركه الى تكوين حكومه اتوقع انها
تكون يعني تحت اشراف المسلحه
لتؤدي مهامها واعتقد ان الان العمل
السياسي والسياسي سيكون خارج اي ممارسه
خلال الفكره المقبله لحين التواضع على
انتخابات عاجله وسريعه اعتقد ان الجيش بعد
الذي حدث لن يسمح مجددا
بعوده دخول الدخول في عمليه سياسيه ويعتقد
ان ما وصفه بمعرفه الكرامه اعتقد انها هي
دون شك ستفدي الى تقديمات تتعلق بالقوات
المسلحه
السوداني الذي كان يطمح الى اخراج القوات
المسلحه السودانيه من العمليه العسكري
العمليه السياسيه تماما في البلاد
نعم نعم ولكن الواقع يشير الى ان الان
القوات المسلحه ربما هي تقول انها مدت
حبال الصبري كثيرا يعني خلقي توافق عريض
من السودانيين والتوافق على اجراءات ولكن
ما حدث ومحاوله الاستنثار بقوه عسكريه
لطرف
ها واستكمال اجراءاتها محدده كمان يعني ظل
يقولها البرهان بان الفيصل بيننا وبين
الاطار هو دمج الدعم السريع والان الدعم
اصبح عمليا من خلال هذه الاجراءات
والمعارك والاشتراكات التي تدور فاذا لن
تكون هناك اي مفاوضات حول ترتيبات للدمج
واعاده هيكله المنظومه العسكريه مجددا
فبالتالي هي واحد
العمليه السياسيه فبالتالي اعتقد ان الان
يعني الجيش ربما يكون له مضرره بان مصلحه
البلاد سياسه البلاد هي اهم من اي محاورات
ومفاوضات اخرى يعني تريد انتاج الازمه
فبالتالي اعتقد ان الوضع الان سيختلف كليا
وان السيناريو لوحه القادم اعتمد ان الجيش
سيتولى الامام اداره البلاد يعني اتوقع
انه
تشكيل حك بتصريف من العسكريين لاداره هذه
لازمه واداره الشؤون البلاد بشكل عام
والولايات فبالتالي اعتقد ان الان يعني
الازمه يعني وفقا الجيش لن تقتضي وجود
مدنين وتنفيذين بل ستكون موكوله الى
القوات من ذلك ان جيش اصبح مستفيدا بشكل
او مستفيدا سياسيا من هذه الازمه الحاليه
سيد خالد نعم
نعم هذا هو الواقع هذه هي الدلائل
والمؤشرات على افضل الواقع ان الجيش ربما
استاذ خالد الفقي يبدو لنا فقد الاتصال مع
ضيفين الخرطوم الكاتب الصحفي خالد الفقيه
مشاهدينا نتابع اذا
هذه الاخبار العاجله مراسل العربيه يتحدث
عن الجيش السوداني ما زال يسيطر على مدينه
مروي وهناك ايضا في سياق الاخبار العاجله
الجيش السوداني يقول ان قواته الجويه دمرت
معسكر طيبه ومعسكر سوبا التابع للدعم
السريع
مصادر العربيه ايضا القاهره طالبت بوقف
اطلاق نار غير مشروط بين الاطراف
السودانيه ومسؤولون مصريون تواصلوا مع
اطراف السودانيه لوقف الاشتباكات الحاليه
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي عادل
السيد احمد عادل معنا في هذه النشره او في
هذه التغطيه بدايه دعنا نبدا من الخبر
العجله بقراته مؤخرا وهو حول تواصل
مسؤولين المصريين مع اطراف السودانيه
الوقف الاشتباكات الحالي هل ترى ان حل هذه
الازمه هو حل دعنا نقول ذا بعد اقليمي
بالطبع يعني اللغه السلاح واللغه
المواجهات
يعني تلعب دور ايضا في طبيعه انجاز اي
تسويه انا اعتقد انه من المهم
الاشاره
خطفوا انني كنت اتحدث مع مصدر عسكري وخبير
سابق مسلحه اشار لي ان وهو يضحك يعني ان
المساله لن تكون اكثر من ساعات او او ايام
قليله باعتبار انه لا يوجد قوه القوات
المسلحه السودانيه قوات راسخه
تاسست منذ يعني اكثر من قرن من الزمان وهي
تملك خبره كبيره جدا وامكانياتها الى انا
اتحدث بشكل فني ولا اتحدث بشكل سياسي من
ناحيه فنيه جيش السوداني مواجهته محطات
جدا من خلال مواجهات عسكريه في 76 ومن
خلال تمرد ايضا حدث في فتره الانقاذ
حيث وصلت قوات من المتمردين حتى يعني شراء
الخرطوم ولكن القوات المسلحه السودانيه
بحسب كلام الخبير العسكري الذي قاله لي لا
يوجد اي تكافل في المعدات ولا في الاسلحه
ولا في الاليات لذلك من المهم جدا ان ان
نشير الى ان الوضع على الارض ينبغي بان
الجيش السوداني يبسط سيطرته بشكل كامل
بحسب سلاح المدرعات وسلاح الطيران والمشاه
مؤسسه
عسكيرته بشكل كامل يدفعه للتساؤل حول مصير
قوات الدعم السريعه التي ترفض عمليه
الدمجه بالاليه التي يطالب بها الجيش اذا
ما كيف ما هو مصير الدعم السريع في هذه
الحاله
الحاله طبعا لغه
السلاح ولغه المواجهه تحسم الامور بشكل
عسكري يعني الان
مع مع الدعم السريع باعت حركه متمرده
وفي الغالب
يعني الجيش يتجه الى خيارين اما التنفع
قوات الدعم السريع
للتسويه السياسيه القائمه على
تسريح قوات الدعم السريع ودمجها في القوات
المسلحه المسلح خلال العامين او ان تقوم
القوات المسلحه
الجهاز صح التعبير على قوى الدعم السريع
وبدات هناك مؤشرات الان تقول بان يعني
عناصر الدعم السريع من العساكر ومن حتى
الضباط وما الى ذلك منهم من عاد الى حضن
الجيش ومنهم من يعني خرب بدا بدا يجهز
امره في الخروج من الخرطوم انا
اعتقدوني عن المقاطعه لكن هل ترى ان هذا
الحل واقعي ويمكن او بامكان الجيش ان ينفذ
هذه المعطيات التي اشرت اليها
يتحدث عن حركه مسلحه عاديه نتحدث عن قوه
دعم سريع وقوامها يفوق 60 الف مقاتل بحسب
بعض التقديرات عن قوات لها نفوذ قبلي واسع
في مناطق مختلفه في السودان عن امكانيات
اقتصاديه ضخمه ايضا لهذه القوات في البلاد
وتتعلم ما يحدث في جبل عامر كيف يمكن اذا
الجيش ان يتعامل مع هذه المعطيات
نعم العسكريه من خلال الوجود على الارض
فانه لا يوجد اي تكافل بين القوات المسلحه
السليمانيه
لذلك وان كنت تتحدث ايضا عن كم فان كم
القوات المسلحه
بالارقام هو اكبر بكثير جدا من من الكم
المرتبط بوابه الدعم انا اعتقد انه لا
نستطيع ان نقول ان هناك طرف يوازي او
يوازن طرف اخر هي الان معركه بين الجيش
نظامي قوه لا تملك من الامكانيات العسكريه
الا النذر اليسير انا اعتقد انه الجيش
السوداني يملك مدرعات يملك سلاح طيران
يملك سلاح يملك امكانيات اتصالات جيده كل
هذه الاشياء ستجعل من من المساله لا تاخذ
لا تستغرق وقتا طويلا لذلك انا اقول لك من
خلال المعلومات فنيه ومن خلال معلومات
وارده من الخبراء مهنيين لا لا علاقه لهم
باي جانب سياسي يقولون ان المساله لن
تتجاوز الايام
وستحسب بقدر او في ضمن قياسي هذا لا يمنع
ان تكون هناك تحركات من اجل التسويه من
اجل ايجاد حلول سياسيه وانا اعتقد انه بعد
هذه المواجهات في خلال الساعات الماضيه
رغم الخسائر التي بدات تتراها لنا الا ان
الصوت العقل من الممكن ان يحقق اختراقا
يعيد الامور الى نصاب نعم لكن ضيفنا سابقا
الاستاذ خالد الفلكي كان يتفق مع وجهه
النظر التي تقول ان هذه المواجهات الان قد
اطلقت رصاصه الرحمه على العمليه السياسيه
في السودان وما صاحبها ايضا من اتفاق
اطاري والتوقيع الاتفاق النهائي ايضا
المزمع تنفيذه يعني هل تتفق مع هذا الطرح
ايضا
لا مساله علاقه بشكل مباشر صحيح ان الحرب
لها كلام ما في شك في ذلك
[موسيقى]
ان القوات الدعم السريع اعتادت ان تعمل
تحت مظله القوات المسلحه
لا بد من استشاره واخطار القوات المسلحه
انا اعتقد انه الاجراء او التصرف الذي تم
من الدعم السريع
بعدم اختاره الوطن المسلحه كان خطا كبير
جدا هو الذي دفع الامور في هذا الاتجاه
انا لا اعتقد انه
الجانب السياسي هو جانب مباشر صحيح ان
هناك
حول هل يتم
دمج القوات الدعم السريع خلال عشر سنوات
ولا خلال عامين انا اعتقد مثلا ما كانت
معضله طالما ان الاطراف متفقه على الدمج
انا اعتقد انه الذي الهب المساله هو تحرك
وتدعم السريع دون اذن ودون تنسيق مع
القوات المسلحه السودان طيب تفضل يا استاذ
عادل الكاتب الصحفي ساعود اليكم من جديد
في سياق هذه التغطيه وانتقل الان مشاهدينا
الى ضيفنا الصحفيه الاستاذ خالد الفقي من
جديد اهلا بك سيد خالد بدايه من الذي يملك
زاما مبادره لوقف حمام الدم وحمايه
السودان من السقوط في اوحل الحرب الاهليه
من القادر في تقديرك على التاثير على جميع
الاطراف
[موسيقى]
فبالتالي اعتقد ان الان الكل يتحمل
المسؤوليه
سوداني يتحمل المسؤوليه ويتحمل مسؤوليه
عدم يعني الاستماع لسوره العقل عدم الجنوح
الى الحكمه الان نحن احوج ما نكون نعم في
هذه اللحظه
للنظر الى معاناه الاوضاع بناء النظر الى
الاستاذ خالد اسمح لي فقط بالاشاره هذا
الخبر العاجل التلفزيون السوداني يتحدث
هذه اللحظات عن وجود اشتباكات في مقره
ودوره اطلاق نار اذا مشاهدينا التلفزيون
السوداني يتحدث عن وجود اشتباكات في مقره
في ام درمان ودوي اطلاقي نار تفضل السيد
خالد
نعم نعم يعني هذا المناطق هذا هذا الان
الصراع والحرب اصبح على محاوله القطر على
مؤسسه الدوله الاستراتيجيه محاوله الان
يعني في ظل
الحان الموجوده الان كل طلب من ان يصدر
بيانات الان هناك حربانيه كثيفه الان نكتب
بشكل واسع في المعلومات
الان تساعد في كثير من المعلومات غير
الحقيقيه فبالتالي اعتقد ان الان على
السودانيين وقتي الان اي
يعني مثل اي معلومات غير مؤكد وغيرها يعني
موثوق منها لانها يعني تساعد على نشره
الشاليهات تساعد على التظليل تساعد على
ادخال حاله من الفزع والقلق للمواطن
العادي الان ردهم في منطقه لا يدري ماذا
يحدث فبالتالي اعتقد ان الاوان في هذه
اللحظه
السودانيين ان يقولوا ان ما يحدث الان لن
ينتج الا ازمه عميقه لن ينتج الا حرب
اهليه لانه الا شرخي في بين المكونات
السودانيه الان نحن في امس الحوجه الى
توحيد اللحمه الوطنيه الى النظر الى ضروره
توفر الامن والاستقرار الاستفاده من تجارب
سابقه كنا نخوضها
نقول انما يحدث الان ما هو الا شيطان
التفاصيل الذي حدثنا منه فبالتالي عدد
العقلاء ان يوقفوا نشاهده
الان عمري موسي يعني الان
العواجل يعني التي نشاهدها في الفضائيات
يعني ممتعه ويعني امري يعني يعني يجعلنا
في حيره من امرنا هل ما هو سيناريو الاقرب
سنين انا قبل الوقت حددتها من السيناريو
الليبي واقامه
حكومه في الشمال وفي الشرق في ظل الصراع
السياسي
ومحاوله
المسلح اللي انت حذفنا منه كثيرا
بالمقاطعتك هنا وساعود اليك في سياق هذه
التغطيه ننتقل الان الى ضيفنا الى مراسلنا
في الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
اهلا بك من معلومات
تطورات عديده البيانات التي ظهرت لكن الان
هناك انباع عن بعض الاصابات في المدنيين
انا لا نتوجه الى المستشفى الدولي في
ذكروا بان هناك اصابتين حتى لا انسي
المستشفى الدولي بسبب انطلاق النار الذي
كان هنا في شارع المعونه في بحري انا الان
امام المستشفى الدولي للتاكد من
لاجل ان التقي بالحالات التي اصيبت الان
في هذه اللحظات هذا بالاضافه الى البيانات
التي صدرت احمد كان اخرها البيان الذي صدر
عن الجيش السوداني والذي ذكر انها قائد
انهم دمروا اكثر من 80 عربه لمليشيا الدعم
السريع المدعومه خارجيا وهروب البقيه
لمنطقه جبل غزاله لتحتمي بالمدنيين في
مدينه مروي ايضا الجيش ذكر بان قائد الدعم
سريع في ولايه النيل الابيض سلم جميع
قواته ومعسكراته وم لقياده الجيش بولايه
الابيض واعداه للقتال الى جانبها انا الان
امام المستشفى الدولي احمد
سابدا في اجراء جوله للتحدث مع احد
المصابين
طيب اذا هو المستشفى الدولي في منطقه بحري
في الخرطوم وهو الامور العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سيكون هناك حاضرا لمتابعه الاخبار
التي تحدث عن اصابات بين المدنيين في هذه
المنطقه مشاهدينا الاخبار العاجله الجيش
السوداني يقول ان قائد الدعم بولايه النيل
الابيض سلم جميع قواته ومعسكراته الجيش
السوداني يقول انه دمر اكثر من ثمانين
عربه للدعم السريع في مدينه مروي الشمالي
البلاد والتلفزيون السوداني ايضا يتحدث عن
وجود اشتباكات في مقره ودوي اطلاق نار
[موسيقى]
متابع معكم هذه الصور المتداوله لتحقيق
طائرات عسكريه سودانيه طائره هليكوبتر
التابع للقوات المسلحه السودانيه وهي تحلق
فوق سماء الخرطوم اذا مشاهدينا نتابع معكم
هذه الصور لمروحيات تابعه للجيش السوداني
تحلق في اجواء العاصمه الخرطوم في ظل
الاشتباكات الدائره حاليا بين قوات الدعم
السريع وقوات الجيش السوداني ومن حيث
المتابع لتصريحات ايضا القوات المسلحه
السودانيه
تعبر شكل واضح عن سيطرتها على الاوضاع في
العاصمه الخرطوم وفي بقيه المناطق قبل
قليل مشاهدينا يقول ان قائد الدعم السريع
بولايه النيل الابيض سلم جميع قواته
ومعسكراته ويقول ايضا انه دمر اكثر من 80
عربا للدعم السريع في مدينه مروي شمال
البلاد الى مشاهدينا الطيران الحربي حاضر
في هذه المعارك التي تشهدها العاصمه
الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى ايضا في السودان كما
نتابع هذه الصور لمروح يات تابعه للجيش
السوداني والتي تحلق في اجواء العاصمه
الخرطوم دعونا نستمع الى صوت هذه الصور
بصوتها الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا شاهد التلفزيون السوداني قطاعا
لبثه بعد سماع دوي لاطلاق النار اثناء
تغطيه الاحداث الجاريه في البلاد نتابع
في داخل الهيئه العامه للاذاعه والتلفزيون
في التلفزيون السودان وفي الاذاعه
السودانيه الان الاحوال هادئه
ونحاول ان نتواصل مع بعض المحللين لنقف
على ابعاد ما يحدث الان وما نستمع
الى مشاهدينا كنا معكم في متابعه لهذا
المقطع السوداني الذي يتحدث عن وجود
اشتباكاته في مقره ودوي اطلاق النار وقد
شهد بثه القطاعا بعد سماع ذوي الاطلاق
النار اثناء تغطيه الاحداث الجاريه في
البلاد مشاهدينا نتابع ايضا مره اخرى هذه
الصور المتداوله للمروحيات التابعه للجيش
السوداني والتي تحلق في اجواء العاصمه
الخرطوم في ظل هذه الاشتباكات الكبيره
الدائره بين قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
نعود مره اخرى ايضا الى ضيفنا اذا كان
متواجدا معنا الاستاذ عادل سيدي احمد
طيب استاذ خالد الفقي
مرحبا بكم من جديد
تتحدث قبل قليل عن السيناريو الليبي وهناك
من يتحدث عن ان هناك العديد من الامثله في
المحيط المحيطين العربي والعالمي لنماذج
من الصراعات التي كانت لها مالات قاسيه
على هذه البلدان ومن المفترض ان يستلهم
منها الشعب السوداني والقياده السودانيه
الدروس والعبر هل ترى ان السيناريو الليبي
او هناك سيناريوهات اخرى مشابهه يمكن ان
تطبق في السودان لا سمح الله
عدد من القنوات من بين العربيه الحدث والى
الليبي
ولكن بعد ما يجري الان
والمعركه التي يعني الان يبدو ان القات
المسلحه اتخذت اجراءات
حزمه من خلال استخدام اليات ووحدات حاسمه
مثل الطيران الحربي مثل المدرعات فبالتالي
الان يبدو
القصه اصبحت واضحه من خلال نظره الخبراء
العسكريين بما يعني لدى القوات المسلحه من
ادوات
يبدو ان الان يعني هذه المعركه من خلال ما
يدري لن تدوم طويلا وربما تكون هي في وقت
يعني اذا محل المساء بحرب العصابات او حرب
الشوارع في محاولات ملاحظه
ويعني قطع الطريق الامداد امام قوات الدعم
السريع اعتقد الان المعركه هي معرفه كما
تقول الجيش السوداني الكرامه
ورا يجري
يعني عمليه
حاولت استعاده السيطره على
اتخاذ القرار لان من بين الاشكاليات التي
كان يختلف حول
الجيش فيما يتعلق بالقياده والسيطره
وتحريك للقوات وربما تحريك القوات الدم
الى مروي كانت هي بمثابه
التي يعني
العلاقه بين القوتين فبالتالي اعتمد ان
القوات المسلحه الان تنظر الى الدعم
السريع نظر مختلفه وانه يجب اخطاء هذه
القوه جبرا الى امرتها الان اعتقد ان الان
من خلال استخدام هذه الوحدات والتدخل
العسكري الحاكم مثل وحدات
الخاصه في المظلات اعتقد باننا الان الجنس
السوداني لم يسمح مجددا لاي قوه اخرى ان
تكون خارجه فبالتالي اعود واجدد
التوقعات والتحليل فيما ان الجيش لم يسمح
الا بحكومه يعني يشرف عليها
ويضعها والعنوان الاكبر والحفاظ على سياده
الامن والاستقرار
له ضيفنا
وما يؤكد حديثك ايضا ما ذهب اليه الجيش
السوداني الذي يقول ان قائد الدعم السريع
بالنيل الابيض اعلن انضمامه الى قوات
الجيش كيف تعلق على هذه النقطه تحديدا
استاذ خالد
ان الجيش
طيب يبدو اننا فقط الاتصال مره اخرى
بضيفنا من الخرطوم الاستاذ خالد الفقي عود
مره اخرى الى ضيفنا الكاتب الصحفي عادل
سيدي احمد عادل من جديد
اصحاب نظريه المؤامره لهم حضور ايضا في
تحليل هذه الاحداث بعضهم يرى ان ما يحدث
حاليا لا يخرج عن كونه تكتيكا سياسيا
وعسكريا مفتعلا بين الطرفين المتحاربين
ربما لمقايضه الامن بالمشاركه في السلطه
مستقبلا على اعتبار ان الاتفاق النهائي
كان سيخرج او سيضمن خروج العسكر من السلطه
هل تتفق مع هذا الطرح
انا لا اميل كثيرا الى نظريه المؤامره
وانما احسب حسابات المسائل بحسب ما اقراه
من الواقع الذي يظهر امامي انا اعتقد انه
عاوز اعلق على حاجتين الحاجه الاولى انه
الخلاف بين الدعم السريع وبين القوات
المسلحه داخل الاتفاق الايطالي
وكان مفهوم ومنطقي وطبيعي لانه اصلا
الاطراف
تتناغش وتتحاور وتختلف وتتفق ولكن الخطوه
التي اقدم عليها الدعم السريع
بتحريك قوات تابعه له الى شمال السودان
والى منطقه مروي دون التشاور والتنسيق مع
القوات المسلحه
انطباع كانما
الدعم السريع يضع نفسه في قصه مع القوات
المسلحه وهذا الثقل غير غير طبيعي وغير
صحيح قوات الدعم السريع اصلا قامت كغوات
مسانده للقوات المسلحه بغض النظر عن
ملابسات انشائها ولكنها في الاصل قامت
كقوه مسانده للغواطن المسلحه وتعمل تحت
امرتها بحسب القانون انا اعتقد انه الذي
حدث في مروي من قبل القوات الدعم السريع
هو الذي استفز القوات المسلحه
واعطى الانطباع لدعم السريع بانه يستطيع
بعد وجود داخل الاتفاق الايطالي ان ينقل
المعركه الى الخارج وان يعطي الانطباع
بانه في كفه موازيه او مساويه لكفضل مسلحه
هذا الامر يستفز القوات المسلحه كثيرا
واظهر المساله بانها غير مقبوله للوطن
المسلحه
دي النقطه الاولى اللي انا عايز اعلق
عليها النقطه الثانيه
كما تفضل زميلي خالد الفقي
ومحاوله ان يصف او يوصف الحاله دي لانها
اشبه بالسيناريو الليبي انا من خلال
معلومات ومن خلال معرفه باطراف
العمليه السياسيه والعسكريه في البلاد ومن
خلال
[موسيقى]
واستطاع الجيش وفي بعض
الرؤيه سيد عادل يعني هل تعتقد او ترى ان
الجيش السوداني كان ينتظر هذه الفرصه اذا
لازاحه الدعم السريع من المشهد طيب قبل ان
اكمل السؤال يسمح لي فقط لمتابعه هذه
الصور التي متداوله لطائرات حربيه
تابعه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه وهي تحلق
فوق سماء العاصمه السودانيه كما نسمع ايضا
بالصوت الطبيعي في هذه اللحظات
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم ينضم لنا رئيس
التحرير صحيفه الجريده اشرف عبد العزيز
اهلا بك سيد اشرف معنا في هذه التغطيه
وبدايه كيف تعلق على ما يحدث الان في
الخرطوم ومروريه وبقيه المناطق السودانيه
متوقع من قبل تشير من المحللين والمراقبين
لان
في اوساط الجيش والدعم السريع وصلت الى
حافه الهاويه فكان هنالك تحشيدا كبيرا
وكانت هنالك
تربصا من قبل كل الاطراف في اطار الخلافات
التي وقعت بين الطرفين خاصه في كابي
نه والذي يتم استبصار شافتها بالرغم من
الجهود المختلفه التي قامت بها القوى
السياسيه والوسطاء الذين يتوسطون لحل
الازمه السودانيه
اكيد
التصريحات والبيانات المختلفه
ومحاوله
السماع من قبل القيادات الى ان من يحقق
الضربه الاولى الخ
اطفه المعركه وهذه بالتاكيد وراها كثير من
المحرضون الذين يرون انه لابد ان تضبوا
الفوضى في السودان حتى يستطيعون العوده
الى شده الحكم مره اخرى
طيب الان نتابع خبر عاجلا للاشراف السعودي
تدعو المكونه على عسكريه والقيادات
السياسيه في السودان لضبط النفس وقبل اذا
كان هناك خبر عاجل حول جهود مصريه
واتصالات مصريه مع القيادات في السودان
لتقريب وجهات النظر ايضا ووقف هذه الازمه
والهذه المعارك للدائره الان في مناطق
مختلفه في الخرطوم وفي مروي ايضا هل تعتقد
ان حل هذه الازمه يحمل ابعاد الاقليميه
ايضا سيد اشرف ام ان الحل هو فقط حل
سوداني سوداني
لان السودان اذا تاذى فهذا يعني
وحصل له هذه الحرب الذي ستؤدي به الى
الطوفان والدرك الصحيح هذا يعني ان الدول
التي تجاوره جميعها سوف تضرر وخاصه التي
تربطها المصالح مع الخرطوم السعوديه مثلا
بالنسبه لها مساله ان البحر الاحمر مهم
جدا وضروري واساسي باعتبار انه يؤمن
حدودها الغربيه
بالنسبه يعتبر التحرك الرمال ساكنه في
السودان يمكن ان يؤثر عليها بقدر كبير
فيما يتعلق بانها القومي وكذلك بقيت دول
غربي افريقيا اذا هنالك
لا بد لمواسع اتجاه هذه الازمه السودانيه
لان ضررها لن يتوقف عند حدود السودان فحسب
كل المنطقه خاصه في ظلم التكهنات بعمليه
حسم المعركه
بالضربه السريعه هذا اذا لم يحدث وهذا
يعني من ستثير في هذا الاتجاه وهذه ليست
معركه منتصر او مهزوم لان في النهايه
الضرر الاول هنا هو الشعب السوداني الذي
يرفض هذه الحرب وحتى عندما خرج للثوره كان
يتحدث عن السلميه ولا يريد ان يقع في اي
حروب دروس ويعلم مدى انها يمكن ان تؤذن
موقف القضيه السودانيه الى طيب واذا عدنا
هذه المعارك الدائره حاليا يعني ما كان
يجري في الغرف المغلقه وعلى مستوى اللجان
واللقاءات والمشاورات حول الاتفاق النهائي
هل كان هناك ما يشيء بامكانيه انزلاق
انزلاق الاوضاع الى هذا الحد
في موقفه هل هو موقف يعتبر جزء من الحقيقه
الموضوعيه بالتاكيد نعم الدعم السريع
يتحدث عن رئيس مدني ومجلس وزراء
الايطالي بكل موت من هو فالمقابل الجيش
ايضا يطرح ترحم موضوعين وراء ان ذلك لن
يتم الا من خلال عمليه اصلاح امني وعسكري
وهذا الاصلاح الامني والعسكري يجب ان يكون
فيه يتم دمج الدعم السريع بعجل ما تيسر
وبالتالي هذا ما جعل امكانيه ان يتحرك
المتربصون في الوسط ويحاولون التحريض
والنفخ في النيران حتى تشتهر تصل الى هذه
المنطقه
يسمون بالفنون النظام السابق يمكن ان يتصل
نتيجه هذه المعركه التي ستح المعرفه من
حرب بين القوات الى حرب
مجتمعيه حرب اهليه بالتاكيد
يعني من الذي عنيته بالمتربصين في هذه
الحاله هل تعني ما ذهب اليه قوات الحريه
والتغيير قوات الحريه والتغيير التي
اشارني النظام السابقون يقفون وراء ما
يحدث الان
التواصل الاجتماعي الذين كانوا ينفقون
النيران ويحاولون اشعال الفتنه هذه ويرون
ان عبر الفوضى يمكن ان يسيطروا على
الاوضاع من جديد هذه لا تحتاج الى سفر
اغوار لاكتشافها هي واضحه ولكن الصفحه
الرسميه لحزب المؤتمر الوطني المحلول
اشارت قبل يومين تقريبا بانها
ان الجي ان الحزب المحلول يقف صفا واحدا
مع القوات المسلحه السودانيه هل تعرف ذلك
تحريضا ايضا على الفتنه بين الطرفين في
اطار الموقف التحريضيه وليس في اطار
المواقف القوميه التي يعني من السلطه ان
ينطلق منها هو يعلم ان هنالك ازمه وانها
عندما ينحاز
هذه الازمه من الذي جاب بقوات الدعم
السريه وعمل على تاسيسها هو ذات الحزب
الذي يرى القوات المسلحه لابد ان تحسم هذه
القوات بهذه الطريقه التي يمكن ان تؤثر
الامن البلاد الخوفي وهو هو من عمل على
هذه البلاد حتى ان الرئيس البشير قال هي
مخزون للاستراتيجي عندما خاطب قوات الدعم
السريع في اواخر اذا هذه واحده من
الاشكالات التي
تحسن انها كانت موجوده فكان من الافضل ان
يزعم في الحل ثم بعد ذلك يؤكد ليس هنالك
سوداني
ضد الحركات المسلحه او كل الدعم السريع او
كل القوات
في جذر ولكن لا
بد اليها بطريقه سلميها دون الوصول الى اي
مما حكاه ان تؤدي الى هذا الشكل لان
النهايه
ايضا هذه الصور التي قناه العربيه الان
وهي صور خاصه بقناه العربيه
اصابات بين المدنيين في داخل المستشفى
الدولي في منطقه الخرطوم بحري اذا هذه
الصور من داخل المستشفى الدولي حيث تتوافد
الاصابات بين المدنيين الى هذا المستشفى
على في سياق المعارك الدائره الحاليه في
الخرطوم والتي لم تسلم منها مناطق الخرطوم
الثلاث نتحدث عنهم درمان او ان كانت اقل
نسبيه من بقيه المناطق نتحدث عن منطقه
الخرطوم بحري والخرطوم العاصمه ايضا اذا
هذه الصور
للمصابين من المدنيين في احدى في احد
مستشفيات العاصمه الخرطوم جراء هذه
المعارك الدائره هناك ايضا اشتباكات
مشاهدينا في منطقه الاوبيض في منطقه
الفاشر ايضا
غرب السودان هناك في مروي في مناطق مختلفه
من السودان ونتابع معكم هذه الصور
للاصابات في مستشفى الخرطوم جراء المعارك
نذكر ايضا مشاهدينا بالاخبار العاجله
الوارده تباعنا المبعوث الامم في السودان
يدعوا لوقف فوري للقتال لضمان سلامه الشعب
الجيش السوداني العربيه يقول نعمل على
السيطره على مواقع الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم والولايات الجيش السوداني العربيه
يقول لا صحه لسيطره الدعم السريع على
المطار والقصر والمقرات الحيويه
اعود مره اخرى الى ضيفي اذا كان متواجدا
معنا الاستاذ اشرف عبد العزيز اشرف وانت
طبعا رئيس تحري الصحيفه والصحفي مرموق
بالتاكيد ولك من المصادم يمكن ان تؤكد به
بعض الاخبار
المتناقضه لا ادري كانت توفت لك معلومات
حول هذا التناقض حول مصير مطار الخرطوم
والقصر الرئاسي في الوقت الذي يقول فيه
الدعم انه سيطر على هذه المقرات ينفي
الجيش ذلك هل توفرت لك معلومات حول ذلك
على مطار الخرطوم او مطار الذي استطاع
الجيش بحسب اخرى
الدعم السريع منه لكن اقول انه دائما في
لحظات وقوع المعرفه من الصعب جدا
الاعتماد على الاخبار التي تصدر من كل
الاطراف لانه في هذه اللحظه هي الاخبار
جزء من المعرفه نفسها في اطار الحرب
النفسيه وبالتالي حتى الان
لم ينجيل الموقف بشكل حقيقي حتى اواخر
الليل وربما ستكون الامور واضحه وصباح
الغد بان من الذي يسيطر على المواقع واكمل
سيطرته عليها تماما لان المعركه هي ما
زالت مستمره وداريه وتختلف فيها انواع
الاسلحه المختلفه
مع الاراء التي تشير الى ان هذه المعارك
ربما تكتب نهايه او تدق المسمار الاخير
كما يقال في النعشه الدعم السريع يعني هل
تعتقد ان الجيش كان ينتظر هذه الفرصه
لازاحه الدعم السلمي المشهد لان هناك
تصريحات ايضا كانت اليوم الجيش السودانيه
يقول فيها بانه ان هذه المعركه تاخرت
كثيرا بحسم هذه الصور من التمرد في البلاد
معرفه هذه معزوفه
ستجرها ويلات كثيره لان سيتاثر بها
المجتمع السوداني وسيحصل الفرز والقسم
نتيجه خطاب الكراهيه المستنير في الفتره
الفائزه الذي سبق المرحله ونتيجه السلطان
الحد في تقديري ينبغي التروي والتعقل من
قبل القيادات هذه القوات
الان ومن ثم حل هذه المساله عبر تصفيه
بدلا من حل هذه المساله باستمرار المعرفه
وانجلائها حتى النهايه لان ذلك سيكون فيه
اشكالا كبيرا على المجتمع السوداني وسيؤثر
على مستقبل وجوده وستنشر حرب اهليه اخرى
حتى بين المواطنين طيب هل تعتقد ان احداث
اليوم ستفرض واقعا جديدا حول تعدد الجيوش
في السودان وانتشارها ايضا في العاصمه مع
اخذ الاعتبار طبعا هذه كانت من ضمن
المطالب التي ينادي بها السودانيون كثيرا
في الاونه الاخيره
لان الحل السياسي هو الاصل في هذه القضيه
فمهما كانت هنالك حلول فرض الامر الواقع
حتى من الجهه التي تنتصر على الاخرى
وبالتاكيد هذا لن يعني ان الامور ستقول
الى السيطره بيدها الجهه الذي ستسيطر لكن
سيكون هنالك متسعه جالس يرفض اليه
المهالات والاحداث ويرى انه لا بد من
مدنيه الدوله السودانيه الله امرا حتميا
حتى وان تبقى اكثر من ثلاثه سودانيين
يعيشون على سماح هذا الوطن فبالتاكيد حتى
من يفعل ومن يريد الفوضى ومن يفعل اي شيء
في نهايه الامر سيواجه هذا الوسط القوي من
قبل الجماهير الشعب السوداني الذي لم تقل
كلمتها
تحت هذه الضغوط لان بعد ايام ربما لا يجب
المواطن على المقاطعه مره اخرى ان نتابع
الان معك ومع ساده المشاهدين هذه الصور
للفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس المجلس
السيادي وهو يتابع مجريات هذه العمليه او
هذه العمليات او المعارك الدائره في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا صور
مشاهدينا تظهر اداره رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهاني غرفه
القياده العسكريه وهذا ما اكده الجيش
السوداني في تصريحات سابقه بان البرهان
فيما كان امن ويتابع بنفسه هذه العمليات
واذا هذه صور مشاهدينا من داخل الغرفه
غرفه القياده العسكريه وتظهر اداره رئيس
وتظهر اداره رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح ابو برهان لهذه الغرفه لعمليات
العسكريه الجاريه الان في الخرطوم ومناطق
سودانيه مختلفه بين قوات الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيه والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات